TERRY RYAN: Today we're talking
about Config Connector, Windows
Server on GKE, and some
SRE advice on Toil.
I'm Terry Ryan and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Config Connector is
a Kubernetes operator
that makes all GCP
resources behave as if they
were Kubernetes resources.
The idea was to simplify
operations and resource
management by providing a single
way to manage your entire cloud
infrastructure
through Kubernetes.
And now that idea has
graduated from beta
and is generally available.
In other Kubernetes news,
Windows Server containers
can now run on Google
Kubernetes Engine in beta.
If you're interested in
trying your containers on GKE,
we've got plenty of resources
to help you get started.
And, of course, our
Kubernetes Community
deserves a huge shout-out for
bringing Kubernetes support
to Windows Server last year.
You're the ones that
got this ball rolling.
Our Site Reliability
Engineers, or SREs,
have faced immense challenges
over Google's history
and every so often one
will share some advice.
This week that advice centers
around identifying and tracking
Toil.
Toil is any work that is
manual and repetitive,
like handling quota requests.
But to reduce Toil and
get back to engineering,
you first need to
identify and measure it.
So check out this breakdown
and let us know if it helps.
Game Developer Conference
2020 is happening March 16
through the 20 in San Francisco.
Whether you'll be there
in person or following
along online, we're stoked
to offer developer sessions
for using Google solutions
to build great games.
If you want to follow
along, be sure to sign up
for announcements and
access to our livestream.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts, ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.